having sex with an animal including a
cow is illegal in England and is
considered an act of animal cruelty
maybe you hitting it right though what
if that Cadillac
so you can kill the cow for steak
get it pregnant steal the baby drain all
the milk
that's fine
but don't [__] it
the punishment for having sex with a cow
in England depends on the severity of
the offense how do you determine the
severity of what you're doing with the
cow if they have you on tape and you're
just like you know you're just pounding
away is that like the severity of it
that you're slapping the Cow's Ass the
maximum sentence for sexual penetration
with a living animal and causing
unnecessary suffering to to a protected
animal is two years in prison
wow you know what we learned is
don't have sex with a cow